Jake from State Farm here this is build
your squad and I'm here to pick the best
possible team I can from forty niners
and Kansas City chief roster we have $15
let's go do it guys start with the
quarterback
we got gentlemen tennis Steve Young
catching mahomes Lynn Dawson and Alex
Smith tough one for me I think I'm gonna
go with Patrick go home I'm going with
the current guy he's only $3.00 which i
think is it steal some putting $3.00
down on him nice and easy okay now you
go with the running back this one you
know I think I'm going to mo Chou's I
think he's really underrated that's
always a great player ask me I can go I
win with him I hear just the way I'm
gonna I'm gonna go up I'm gonna go for
the best of the best
I'm picking Jerry Rice here unbelievable
it been just a great place to go out
make plays for Patrick my home - all
right played number four I'm gonna go
with Eric Berry man love him love his
story love his toughness I think he's a
great football player unbelievable
talent here goes four dollars for Eric
Berry
I gotta go five dollars down for Jerry
Rice I forgot to do that I was trying to
steal it your spot for him leaves me
with two dollars left so I'm going
bright young here
defense alive a big physical guy I'm
gonna play tough Patrick mahomes
unbelievable talent can make all the
throws that need to make partner him
with Jerry Rice can go out make all the
place well I think that duo that's a
great duo it might be a little bit
better than the Joe Montana Steve young
very righteous - oh you know maybe we'll
see you know with or without Ross near
Jamar Charles a great player I think he
was really underrated
I think he should have been worth more
than a dollar here Eric Berry and bright
young - great defenders
love Eric very story and both these guys
play relentless tough fiscal defense I'm
Jake from State Farm and this
is good just watch